This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the annals of TV comedy, there have been many figures with a dour, cynical outlook. But there's one that stands out for her relentlessly pessimistic mindset. Hi, I'm Debbie. Rachel Dratch is unforgettable character from Saturday Night Live. You're enjoying your day, everything's going your way, then alone come stay the downer. You guys, I love wedding come stand, you downer. You guys, I love wedding.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在电视喜剧的编年史中，有许多神情严厉、愤世嫉俗的人物。但有一个人因其坚定不移的悲观心态而脱颖而出。嗨，我是黛比。瑞秋·德拉奇是《周六夜现场》中令人难忘的角色。你正在享受美好的一天，一切都如你所愿，然后扫兴鬼就来了。你们这些人，我喜欢婚礼……来吧，扫兴鬼。你们这些人，我喜欢婚礼。
This one the best ever. Wish I'm luck. The only thing higher than gas prices in this country are divorce rates. Debbie Downer shows up at parties, weddings, and holiday gatherings, always ready to remind people that life is terrible. All right, it wants cake!
这是有史以来最好的一次。祝我好运吧。这个国家里，除了天然气价格之外，唯一比它高的是离婚率。黛比·唐纳会出现在派对、婚礼和节日聚会上，随时准备提醒人们生活是多么糟糕。好了，它想要蛋糕！
I want some. Go, alright, you get to pay. Can you wait? Then for me, with all the refined sugars we're eating, America is experiencing a virtual epidemic of juvenile diabetes. It's a fun, a fun. We all know Debbie Downer's in real life. People who can't help but accentuate the negative,
我想要一些。去吧，好吧，你得付钱。你能等等吗？然后对我来说，随着我们吃的所有精制糖，美国正在经历一场几乎是少年糖尿病的流行。这是一个乐趣，一个乐趣。我们都知道现实生活中的黛比·唐纳。那些情不自禁地强调消极面的人，
who focus on the faults and flaws of others, who always, always see the glass as half empty. A lot of people, that's the one people come up to me and they're like, oh my gosh, that is my sister, that's my mother, like everyone has with Debbie down and they're like, so I think that's why it hit so hard, but um... This week on Hidden Brain, the surprising psychology of mindsets, I think that's why it hit so hard, but um... Can you do that? This week on Hidden Brain, the surprising psychology of mindsets, why they matter and how to master them.
那些专注于他人的缺点和瑕疵的人，那些总是、总是把半满的水杯看作半空的人。很多人，这是人们来找我时会说的人，哦天哪，那是我的我妹妹，那是我的母亲，就像每个人都有黛比·唐纳的影子一样，他们会说，所以我认为这就是为什么它冲击力这么大，但嗯……本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，关于心态的惊人心理学，我认为这就是为什么它冲击力这么大，但嗯……你能做到吗？本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，关于心态的惊人心理学：它们为什么重要以及如何掌握它们。
What we can do with our minds, what we can do with our intention and our energy is incredible and it's a power that we often fail to realize is even there. A quick note that we're doing something a little unusual today, this episode is part one of our story. There's going to be a second part, we'll feature that story in our next episode. It's best to listen to these episodes in order. in order. When most of us think about our problems and challenges, we locate them in barriers and conflicts we experience in the outside world. Your job application gets turned down, your
我们可以用我们的思想做什么，我们可以用我们的意图和能量做什么，这是不可思议的，这是一种我们常常没有意识到甚至存在的力量。简短说明一下，我们今天要做一些不太寻常的事情，这一集是我们故事的第一部分。还将有第二部分，我们将在下一集里播放那个故事。最好按顺序收听这些节目。按顺序收听。当我们大多数人思考我们的问题和挑战时，我们会把它们归结为我们在外部世界经历的障碍和冲突。你的求职申请被拒绝了，你的
partner breaks up with you, you fall sick and find it hard to get out of bed. At Stanford University, psychologist Aliyah Kram has spent a long time thinking about how we perceive the obstacles we confront and how we respond to them. Aliyah Kram, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, it's great to be here. Aliyah, understand that you were a very serious amateur athlete as a child and as a young person from age 4 to 14. You were a competitive gymnast in college. You played division one ice hockey.
伴侣和你分手了，你生病了，发现很难起床。在斯坦福大学，心理学家阿莉娅·克拉姆花了很多时间思考我们如何看待我们面对的障碍以及我们如何应对它们。阿莉娅·克拉姆，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，很高兴来到这里。阿莉娅，据我了解，你在童年以及4岁到14岁的青年时期是一名非常严肃的业余运动员。你在大学里是一名竞技体操运动员。你打过分区一女子冰球。
You later became an internationally ranked triathlete. I want to take you back to your time in college when you were contending with the exertions of your sport. Can you give me a sense of your hockey training regimen? Yeah, being a division one athlete is no joke. It's a full-time job in the midst of already a full-time job of going to college. We trained five days a week.
你后来成为了一名国际排名的铁人三项运动员。我想带你回到大学时期，当时你正在应对这项运动的劳累。你能让我对你的冰球训练计划有个大致的了解吗？是的，作为一个分区一运动员绝非开玩笑。在繁重的大学学业之中，这就像是一份全职工作。我们一周训练五天。
We had two games on the weekend. Practices were two hours followed by strength training after that. It was quite a grind. And did you feel as a result of doing all this exercise that you were doing all that you could do to get in shape? Not at all. Well, the interesting thing is we'd have a two-hour practice,
我们在周末有两场比赛。训练是两个小时，接着是力量训练。这确实是一段苦日子。你是否觉得由于进行了所有这些锻炼，你已经尽你所能去保持身材了？一点也不。有趣的是，我们会进行两小时的训练，
then go to the gym. And then just because I didn't feel like it was quite enough, I would get on the treadmill or the elliptical and get a little extra cardio. One day, as she was taking a run along the Charles River, a set of intrusive thoughts entered her mind. She was letting people down. She was letting herself down. And all my teammates can attest to this.
然后去健身房。仅仅因为我觉得这还不够，我就会走上跑步机或椭圆机，做一点额外的有氧运动。有一天，当她沿着查尔斯河跑步时，一系列侵入性的想法进入了她的脑海。她让人们失望了。她让自己失望了。我所有的队友都可以为此作证。
They're like, you know, there was a few of us who had this sort of like feeling of scarcity. Like we just weren't doing quite enough and we needed to do more. And you know, it was just this persistent feeling of, this is not enough. I'm not doing enough. And I remember, I'll never forget it running on the Charles that day when I had this Moment of feeling like is it ever enough? Will I ever do enough? Hmm And what about when it came to diet part of what you have to do when you're an athlete? Of course is all the physical conditioning, but presumably you were also paying a great deal of attention to what and how much you ate
他们说，你知道，我们当中有几个人有这种稀缺感。就像我们做得还不够，我们需要做得更多。你知道，这只是一种挥之不去的赶脚，这还不够。我记得，我永远不会忘记那天在查尔斯河跑步时，我有了一种感觉的时刻，那就是：这永远够了吗？我做的事永远够吗？嗯。那么饮食呢？当你是一名运动员时，你必须做的事情之一，当然是所有的身体调理，但据推测，你也非常关注你吃什么以及吃多少。
Yeah, diet is a huge deal for athletes and it's tricky. Different sports have different issues. You're wanting to, as an ice hockey player, you want to gain muscle, but still stay lean so that you're fast and quick on the ice. These are in some ways competing demands. And same with the exercise, just constantly feeling like I wasn't eating right. I was eating too much or eating not the right foods. I was too heavy or not strong enough. Mostly for me, I'm a naturally muscular person, but I always had this feeling like I was gaining weight that I shouldn't have. So there was this constant conflict, constant tension, feeling like
是的，饮食对运动员来说是一件大事，而且很棘手。不同的运动项目有不同的问题。你想要的是，作为一名冰球运动员，你想要增加肌肉，但又要保持苗条，这样你在冰上才能快而敏捷。在某些方面，这些是相互冲突的需求。就像锻炼一样，总是觉得自己吃得不对。我吃得太多了或者没有吃对食物。我太重了或者不够强壮。对大多数人来说，我是一个天生肌肉发达的人，但我总觉得自己在长不该长的体重。所以这里有源源不断的冲突，源源不断的紧张感，让人觉得
I should be eating less. Alia was surrounded by smart, driven people. I asked her if the voices of criticism she constantly heard were coming from the outside or the inside. This was all self-generated. I Kind of had this uncertainty or feeling like I wanted to be in the best shape possible But really not feeling like I was ever there every day was a struggle And did you worry about what others were thinking about you your advisors your coaches your fellow players? Oh constantly, you know as an athlete you're worried that the
我应该少吃点。阿莉娅周围都是聪明、有进取心的人。我问她，她不断听到的批评声音是来自外部还是内部。这些都是自我产生的。我有点这种不确定性或感觉，我希望处于尽可能好的状态，但真的不觉得自己达到了那种状态。每一天都是一场斗争。你是否担心别人对你的看法——你的导师、你的教练、你的队友？哦，经常，你知道，作为一个运动员，你担心
professors Don't think you're as constantly. You know, as an athlete, you're worried that the professors don't think you're as smart or, you know, and as an athlete, you worry that, you know, are you going to live up to playing at the same level as the other teammates that you have played with a number of Olympians? And there was a constant feeling of a vinaticacy, you know, compared to them. and there was a constant feeling of a vinaticity compared to them. Alia was interested in psychology, but didn't have a good way of understanding her own feeling of scarcity, that nothing she did felt like enough. A few years later, now in graduate school, Alia was driving herself as hard as ever. She wasn't just stressed, the fact that she was stressed had itself become a form of stress. She asked herself,
教授们认为你不够……哦，经常，你知道，作为一个运动员，你担心教授们认为你不够聪明，或者，你知道，作为一个运动员，你担心，你是否能达到与你一起打过球的其他队友相同的水平，你曾与多位奥运选手一起打过球。而且总有一种不如人的感觉，你知道，和他们相比。而且总有一种不如人的感觉，你知道，和他们相比。阿莉娅对心理学很感兴趣，但没有一个好的方法来理解她自己那种稀缺感，即她所做的一切都感觉不够。几年后，现在正在读研究生，阿莉娅对自己要求和以前一样严格。她不仅压力山大，她有压力这件事本身也变成了一种压力。她问自己，
what does it mean that I find this so hard? It was grad school for me when the real kind of self-doubt started seeping in as an academic. I think as an undergrad at Harvard, I was mostly just excited to be there, to learn and to grow and to take interesting classes. And I was fortunate enough to get into Yale as a PhD student. And that's when I really started to get stressed. I wanted to have a successful dissertation. I wanted to do research that made a difference.
我发现这这么难，意味着什么？对我和我来说，当真正的自我怀疑开始作为一名学者渗入时，那是在读研究生期间。我想作为哈佛大学的本科生，我大多只是很高兴能去那里，去学习、去成长并参加有趣的课程。我很幸运能作为博士生进入耶鲁大学。也就是在那时，我真正开始感到压力。我希望有一篇成功的学位论文。我希望做能产生影响的研究。
And I wasn't sure if I was doing that. You know, I wasn't sure if I was learning the right things if I had the right ideas, if I was working hard enough, if I knew enough statistics, if I was reading the right papers, there was sort of this constant feeling of self-doubt. And that carried with it a lot of stress, a lot of feeling like I was in this constant state of threat or challenge and wanting to succeed, caring about it so much, but not really feeling like I was in flow, if you will. I wasn't in that state of just, you know,
我不确定我是否在这样做。你知道，我不确定我是否在学正确的东西，我是否有正确的想法，我是否足够努力，我是否了解足够的统计学，我是否在读正确的论文，有一种持续的自我怀疑的感觉。这伴随着大量的压力，大量觉得自己处于这种持续的威胁或挑战状态的感觉，并渴望成功，非常在乎它，但并不真正觉得自己在心流中，如果你愿意这么说的话。我不在那种状态，你知道，
feeling confident in myself. But then one night as she was working late, the world presented a Leah with a little gift, a brief moment of insight. And I'll never forget it. I was, this was about my third year in graduate school and I had my meetings with my advisor, Peter Salovey at 8 a.m. on Friday mornings. And 8 a.m. is still early when you're a grad student. But I always remember sort of frantically Thursdays trying to finish the things that I said I was
对自己感到自信。但后来有一天，正当她深夜工作时，世界向阿莉娅赠送了一份小礼物，一个短暂的顿悟时刻。我永远不会忘记它。我当时，那大约是我读研究生的第三年，我每周五早上8点与我的导师彼得·萨洛维开会。对于一个研究生来说，早上8点依然很早。但我总是记得星期四疯狂地试图完成我所说的我将要
going to do, come to him with a new idea, a new breakthrough, some new analyses. And this one particular night I was working on coming up with the idea that I was going to pursue for my dissertation. So there was a lot of stress about that. Do I have a worthy idea? And I was in the lab late at night. Now they put the grad students at Yale, at least at that time, in the basement
做的事情，带着一个新想法、一个新突破、一些新分析去见他。就在这个特别的夜晚，我正致力于想出我将要为我的学位论文追求的想法。所以对此有很大的压力。我有一个有价值的想法吗？我深夜还在实验室里。现在他们把耶鲁的研究生，至少在当时，安排在心理学系的地下室里。
of the psychology department. That's where they kept the computers with the statistical software. And I was in there late at night, stressed, anxious, feeling self-doubt, frantically trying to run some analyses, come up with some ideas, coming up with something that I could present to my advisor the next morning.
那是他们放置带有统计软件的电脑的地方。我深夜呆在那里，压力重重，焦虑不安，感到自我怀疑，疯狂地试图运行一些分析，想出一些点子，想出一些我第二天早上可以向导师汇报的东西。
Outside the closed doors of the lab, Alia heard footsteps. Yeah, it was late at night, so I didn't think anyone would really be there, but I heard footsteps coming down the door, and you can hear anything in that basement because it's concrete and you know even the slightest move you feel like crack or a creek and you know I perk up I'm like who's here who am I gonna have to talk to I don't have any time to talk you know I'm busy and the door creaked open and in looked Brett Logan. Now Brett was the IT person at Yale. Still is, he's a great guy. And, you know, we were friends, but I didn't have any time to talk to Brett
在实验室紧闭的门外，阿莉娅听到了脚步声。是的，当时已经是深夜了，所以我以为不会真的有人在那里，但我听到脚步声向门走来，你在那个地下室里能听到任何声音，因为它是混凝土的，你知道，哪怕是最轻微的移动，你也会觉得像裂开或吱吱作响，你知道，我振作起来，心想是谁在这儿？我得跟谁说话？我没有时间说话，你知道，我很忙。门吱呀一声开了，布雷特·洛根探头进来看了看。现在布雷特是耶鲁的IT人员。现在仍然是，他是个很棒的人。而且，你知道，我们是朋友，但我没有时间跟布雷特说话
at this particular point in time. So I looked up at him, kind of with this frazzled stress state. And he must have picked up on it because all he said in response to me was, it's just a cold, dark night on the side of Everest. And then shut the door. A cold, dark night on the side of Everest,
在这个特定的时间点。所以我抬头看着他，带着这种精疲力竭的压力状态。他一定察觉到了，因为他对我说的话仅仅是：这只是珠穆朗玛峰侧面一个寒冷黑暗的夜晚。然后关上了门。珠穆朗玛峰侧面一个寒冷黑暗的夜晚，
what do you think he was trying to say, Alia? You know, at the time, I didn't think twice about it. I was just like, okay, Brett went back to my stressing and struggling. But it occurred to me about two weeks later. I remember waking up in the middle of night and thinking and realizing what he meant. So if you were climbing Everest, you could imagine that there'd be some nights that were cold, that were dark, perhaps you'd be tired or strained. But what did you expect?
你觉得他想表达什么，阿莉娅？你知道，当时我没有多想。我只是想，好吧，布雷特回到了我的压力和挣扎中。但大约两周后我突然想到了。我记得在半夜醒来，思考并意识到了他的意思。所以如果你在爬珠穆朗玛峰，你可以想象有些夜晚会很冷，会很黑暗，也许你会感到疲倦或拉伤。但你期待什么呢？
Did you really expect that climbing Everest would be a walk in the park? Would climbing Everest be such a great feat if it was just a walk in the park? No, so what did I expect? Did I expect that getting a PhD making a contribution to the field of psychology was gonna be easy? No, would it be that great of a feat if it were just a walk in the park? No. So I think what Brett meant there or what it meant to me was it really gave me a profound shift in perspective, a profound shift in mindset going from this place of like,
你真的以为爬珠穆朗玛峰会是在公园里散步吗？如果只是在公园里散步，爬珠穆朗玛峰会是如此伟大的壮举吗？不，那我期待什么？我期待获得博士学位、为心理学领域做出贡献会很容易吗？不，如果只是在公园里散步，它会是那么伟大的壮举吗？不。所以我想布雷特在那里的意思，或者它对我的意义，它确实给了我视角上的深刻转变，心态上的深刻转变，从这种地方：
this stress and struggle is a sign that I'm not worthy, that something's wrong, to, oh, this stress, this struggle, this cold, dark night, this is part of the process. This is it. Like, this is what makes you great. What makes you succeed. So in some ways, what you were hearing was that that yes, it's difficult, but it's difficult for a reason. And once you focus on the reason, then in some ways it puts the difficulty
这种压力和挣扎是我不配、有什么不对的标志，转变为：哦，这种压力、这种挣扎、这个寒冷黑暗的夜晚，这是这个过程的一部分。就是这样。就像，这正是让你变得伟大的原因。让你成功的原因。所以在某种程度上，你听到的是，是的，这很困难，但这困难是有原因的。一旦你关注这个原因，那么在某种程度上，它就把困难
into some perspective. 100%. You know, we get messages from everywhere, from public health, from culture, from books, telling us that stress is a bad thing, that it's going to make a sick, it's going to hurt our productivity, and therefore we should avoid it or kind of counteract it. But if you think about the times in your life that you grew the most as a person, or you performed as exceptionally high level as an athlete, or as a professional, or as an individual. And you look back to those times and you ask yourself, did those times involve any stress? The answer invariably is yes, part and parcel of the things that matter to us is stress.
置于某种视角之中。百分之百。你知道，我们从四面八方收到信息，从公共卫生、文化、书籍中，告诉我们压力是一件坏事，它会让我们生病，它会损害我们的生产力，因此我们应该避开它或以某种方式抵消它。但是如果你想想你生活中作为一个人成长最多的时刻，或者作为一名运动员、作为一名专业人士或作为一个人表现出异常高水平的时刻。你回想那些时刻，问问自己，那些时刻包含任何压力吗？答案总是肯定的，对我们重要的事情的一部分就是压力。
Stress is defined as the experience or anticipation of adversity in one's goal-related efforts. That last part is critical, those goal-related efforts. What that means is we don't get stressed about things we don't care about. So if I told you that Johnny was failing school or, you know, Johnny wasn't going to pass his PhD qualification exams, that wouldn't stress you out unless you were Johnny. Or you cared about Johnny or you cared about the Johnny's of the world passing school, right? So you start to realize that stress and our values, our cares, our goals, are two sides of the same coin, you start to get a new approach, you know,
压力被定义为在与目标相关的努力中对逆境的体验或预期。最后一部分至关重要，即那些与目标相关的努力。这意味着我们不会为我们不关心的事感到压力。所以如果我告诉你约翰尼学习不及格，或者，你知道，约翰尼无法通过他的博士资格考试，除非你是约翰尼，否则这不会给你带来压力。或者你在乎约翰尼，或者你在乎世界上像约翰尼这样的人能通过学校考试，对吧？所以你开始意识到压力和我们的价值观、我们的关心、我们的目标是硬币的两面，你开始获得一种新方法，你知道，
a new mindset about the nature of stress. What's interesting, of course, is that when you had this insight about the comment and what the comment might mean, you know, cold, dark night on the side of Everest, it didn't change your circumstances. You were still in grad school. You were still trying to find a dissertation topic.
关于压力本质的新心态。有趣的是，当然，当你对这条评论以及这条评论可能意味着什么有了这种顿悟时，你知道，珠穆朗玛峰侧面寒冷黑暗的夜晚，它并没有改变你的环境。你还在读研究生。你还在试图寻找学位论文的主题。
You were still juggling all the things that you were juggling. And yet, it did make a difference. It made a profound difference. It was game-changing. And you're exactly right. Nothing else changed. It's not like I had a eureka moment in some analyses or that I just advanced a year in my PhD.
你还在兼顾你一直在兼顾的所有事情。然而，它确实产生了影响。它产生了深远的影响。这是颠覆性的。你说得完全正确。其他什么都没有改变。并不是说我在某些分析中有了醍醐灌顶的时刻，也不是说我的博士学位提前了一年。
I was the same person in the same circumstance, doing the same thing with the same meetings and tasks ahead of me. The only thing that changed was my mindset, was my view of stress, of struggle, in this process of getting a PhD. Philosophers, novelists and spiritual counselors have wrestled with the question for centuries.
我是同一个人，在相同的情境下，做着同样的事情，面对着同样的会议和任务。唯一改变的是我的心态，是我对获得博士学位这个过程中的压力、挣扎的看法。哲学家、小说家和精神辅导员几个世纪以来一直在与这个问题搏斗。
The problems we face in our lives are obviously shaped by our experiences in the world, but our perceptions of those problems are also our perceptions, they are shaped by what happens inside our own minds. When we come back, what modern psychological science is finding about the role that our own minds play in our construction of problems and their solutions? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
我们在生活中面临的问题显然是由我们在世界上的经历塑造的，但我们对这些问题的看法也是我们的看法，它们是由我们自己内心发生的事情塑造的。当我们回来时，现代心理学科学发现了关于我们自己的心智在我们构建问题及其解决方案中扮演什么角色的什么内容？您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. How much to our minds shape the way we experience the world? And how much does the way we think shape our ability to respond to challenges and setbacks? Alia Crum is a psychologist at Stanford University. She studies how we interpret and respond to everyday challenges. Her research suggests that while we naturally focus on what appear to be the objective facts of our day-to-day dilemmas and setbacks, these challenges are often shaped in consequential ways by our own minds. Alia, I want to take you back one more time to a defining moment in your athletic career
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们的心智在多大程度上塑造了我们体验世界的方式？我们的思考方式在多大程度上塑造了我们应对挑战和挫折的能力？阿莉娅·克拉姆是斯坦福大学的心理学家。她研究我们如何解释并应对日常挑战。她的研究表明，虽然我们自然而然地关注我们日常困境和挫折中看似客观的事实，但这些挑战往往被我们自己的心智以深刻的方式塑造着。阿莉娅，我想再次带你回到你运动生涯中的一个决定性时刻，
where now going back even earlier into your childhood, you were 10 years old and getting ready for an important gymnastics meet that was going to happen in three days. Can you tell me what your preparations involved and what happened at the gym? Yeah, so I was a very serious gymnast growing up, we trained four hours a day, four days a week with meets on the weekend. And I loved it.
现在甚至要追溯到你的童年，你当时10岁，正在为一个将在三天后举行重要的体操比赛做准备。你能告诉我你的准备工作包括什么，以及在体操馆里发生了什么吗？是的，我从小就是一个非常认真的体操运动员，我们每天训练四个小时，一周四天，周末有比赛。我非常喜欢它。
I was all in gymnastics. I cared about it so much. We had a great group of us doing it. You know, I would come home and get on the beam to do more practices. I just loved it and wanted to excel at the highest level. And I had a chance to do this. I had a chance gym training before the meat and I did a vault. And on the vault, I hit my ankles together so hard, landed wrong and I was limping and I was hurt. And I thought, okay, it must not have been that big of a deal. I'm probably
我全力投入到体操中。我非常在乎它。我们有一群很棒的人在做这件事。你知道，我会回家跳上平衡木进行更多的练习。我只是喜欢它，并希望在最高水平上脱颖而出。我有一个机会做到这一点。我在比赛前有一次在体育馆训练的机会，我做了一个跳马。在跳马时，我的脚踝撞得太厉害了，落地姿势不对，我一瘸一拐的，受伤了。我想，好吧，这一定不是什么大不了的事。我可能
fine. I tried to walk around. I tried to walk it off. But I couldn't walk it off. I had to stop. Ice. And the pain was shocking. It was both physical and also emotional, because I had this immediate sinking feeling of I'm not going to be able to compete.
很好。我试着四处走走。我试着走过去。但我没法走过去。我不得不停下来。冰敷。痛苦是惊人的。它既是身体上的，也是情感上的，因为我有一种直接的下沉感：我将无法比赛。
How bad was it? It sounds like you hit your ankles together, sort of the bony part of the foot that must have been quite painful. Yeah, that bone, little bone in the middle of your ankle that sticks out, those two things hit together. I had to stop that day, I went home, I was distraught, but I was determined. So I had that moment of, oh God, what happened, and then the next feeling was, I must do this, I must compete.
有多严重？听起来你把脚踝撞到了一起，差不多是脚的骨质部位，那一定很痛。是的，骨头，你脚踝中间突出的那小块骨头，那两块东西撞在了一起。那天我不得不停下来，我回家了，我心烦意乱，但我很坚决。所以我当时的感觉是，哦天哪，发生了什么，然后紧接着的感觉是，我必须这样做，我必须去比赛。
So we did everything we could to get it ready. I was icing and wrapping it and elevating it and took care of it as much as I could the next few days. Alia's father told her that healing had to do with her mind, not just her body. My father was a martial artist. He was a master of the art of Ikeido and had done a lot of visualization and energy work. And so I worked with him on my mind at the time. I worked with sending energy to my ankle and I worked with visualizing my routine.
所以我们做了我们能做的一切来为它做准备。接下来的几天里，我一直在冰敷、用绷带包扎、抬高并尽可能地照顾它。阿莉娅的父亲告诉她，疗愈与她的心智有关，而不仅仅是她的身体。我父亲是一名武术家。他是合气道艺术的大师，做过很多视觉化和能量工作。所以当时我和他一起在我的心智上下功夫。我致力于将能量发送到我的脚踝，我致力于将我的动作视觉化。
I knew I couldn't train physically, but I could train in my mind. And the wonderful thing about gymnastics is your routines are preset. So you know exactly what you're going to do and what you should do. And that makes it very easy to visualize. So I spent those few days just visualizing my routine, doing nothing physically, but doing everything mentally.
我知道我不能进行身体训练，但我可以在我的心智中训练。体操的奇妙之处在于你的动作是预先设定的。所以你确切地知道你要做什么以及你应该做什么。这使得视觉化变得非常容易。所以我花了那几天的时间只是把我的动作视觉化，身体上什么也没做，但在精神上做了一切。
Did you get to the regional competition that weekend? I did. We went there, and not only did I get there, I competed on that foot, and I qualified for the National Championship. Wow. So a couple of days later, Lea, you received some news about your ankle. Tell me the news that you received. A few days later, it was still bothering me. You know, the visualization had helped my performance, but it didn't had helped my performance, but it didn't heal the pain completely. I felt no pain during my performances on floor vault being and bars, but after, you know, it wasn't like the ankle, magically, was better. So we went to the hospital and got an x-ray, and I found out that the ankle was very clearly broken. You had competed on a broken ankle and you qualified?
你那个周末去参加地区比赛了吗？去了。我们去了那里，我不仅去了，我用那只脚参加了比赛，并且我获得了全国锦标赛的资格。哇。所以几天后，阿莉娅，你收到了关于你脚踝的一些消息。告诉我你收到的消息。几天后，它仍然在困扰我。你知道，视觉化对我的表现有所帮助，但它并没有……对我的表现有所帮助，但它并没有完全治愈疼痛。我在地板、跳马、平衡木和高低杠上表演时没有感到疼痛，但之后，你知道，这并不是说脚踝神奇地变好了。所以我们去医院拍了X光片，我发现脚踝很明显断了。你带着骨折的脚踝参加比赛并且获得了资格？
That's correct. I mean, that almost seems impossible. It does, right? We think that the world is physical. We think that our bodies are physical and solely physical. And if you have a broken ankle, that should be, you know, career ending or at least competition ending. And what you start, what I learned then very clearly was that the physical is only a portion.
没错。我的意思是，这几乎看起来是不可能的。确实，对吧？我们认为世界是物质的。我们认为我们的身体是物质的，而且完全是物质的。如果你脚踝骨折了，那应该，你知道，是职业生涯的结束，或者至少是比赛的结束。而你开始，我当时非常清楚地了解到的是，物质只是其中的一部分。
It's a very real portion and it shouldn't be totally overridden or discarded. But it still is only a portion. And what we can do with our minds, what we can do with our intention and our energy is incredible. And it's a power that we often fail to realize is even there. And certainly are not fully tapping into it in the ways that I think we can and the ways that I was able to do that day. After you became a psychologist, you became a researcher into the psychology of mindsets and you've used that term a couple of times in our conversation already. Can you explain to us what mindsets are? Yeah, we view mindsets as core assumptions that we make about the nature of
这是一个非常真实的部分，它不应该被完全推翻或抛弃。但它仍然只是一个部分。我们可以用我们的心智做什么，我们可以用我们的意图和能量做什么，这是不可思议的。这是一种我们常常没有意识到甚至存在的权力，当然也没有以我认为我们可以的方式以及我那天能够做到的方式充分利用它。在你成为心理学家之后，你成为了一名心态心理学研究员，你在我们的对话中已经使用过这个词好几次了。你能向我们解释一下什么是心态吗？是的，我们将心态视为我们对自我本质或世界上事物的本质所做出的核心假设。它们是信念，真的。它们是一种信念，但它是一种非常强大的信念，对吧？所以我们对自己的能力或智力有心态，但我们也对其他事情有心态。关于……的心态，但我们也对其他事情有心态。关于……的心态：压力的本质，关于我们自己身体的能力或局限性的心态。关于我们正在吃的食物或我们正在做的锻炼是否足够的的心态。它们的视角、它们的镜头、它们的框架、它们只是关于那些事情的意义
ourselves or things in the world. They're beliefs, really. They're a type of belief, but it's a very powerful type of belief, right? So we have mindsets about our own abilities or our intelligence, but we also have mindsets about other things. Mindsets about the But we also have mindsets about other things. Mindsets about the nature of stress, mindsets about the capabilities or limitations of our own bodies. Mindsets about the enoughness of the foods that we're eating or the exercise we're doing. Their perspectives, their lenses, their frameworks, their just assumptions about the meaning
或本质的假设。因此，当你开始进行这项研究时，你发现的事情之一是，不仅我们很多人不了解心态的力量，我们很多人甚至没有意识到我们有心态。我认为这也许是所有发现中最深刻的觉悟，对吧？这令人兴奋，我们可以谈论心态的所有分支，它们如何改变我们的注意力、我们的情感、我们的生理和我们的行为。
or the nature of those things. So one of the things that you discovered as you started engaging in this research is that it's not just the case that many of us don't understand the power of mindsets. Many of us don't even realize that we have mindsets. I think that is perhaps the most profound realization of all, right? It's exciting and we can talk about all the ramifications of mindsets, how they change our attention, our affect, our physiology, and our behavior.
但在那之前退一步，就是意识到我们有心态。你知道，通常情况下，我们认为我们的信念、我们的经历是对客观存在的世界的直接反映。而你最终意识到的是，事实根本并非如此。我们的感知、我们的信念、我们的经历永远是一种解释。它们总是通过我们拥有的镜头、我们的心态进行过滤。我想谈谈一些研究以及心态似乎影响我们的方式。
But to go back a step before that is to realize that we have mindsets. You know, so often we think that our beliefs, our experiences, are a direct reflection of the world as it objectively is. And what you come to realize is that is just not the case. Our perceptions, our beliefs, our experiences are always an interpretation. They're always filtered through the lenses, the mindsets that we have. I'd like to talk about some of the research and the ways in which mindset seem to influence us.
它们似乎在做的事情之一是，它们似乎塑造了我们的期望，我们对将要发生的事情的预测。在某种程度上，我认为你在那天的地区比赛中在体操场上发生的事情也是如此。你的期望，你对你将要做的事情的预测，最终塑造了你实际做的事情。你能谈谈这个观点吗，即心态的一个强大影响是它们塑造了我们对世界的期望？是的，所以你可以想象，如果，你知道，我那天去找医生，他们说，你的脚踝骨折了，你不能比赛，对吧？那将是一种心态。那种脚踝骨折了、你将无法比赛、你会感到疼痛、你会
One of the things they seem to do is they seem to shape our expectations, our predictions about what will happen. And to some extent, I think that's true of what happened with you on that gymnastics floor that day at the regional competition. Your expectations, your predictions about what you were going to do ended up shaping what you actually did. Can you talk about this idea that one powerful effect that mindsets have is that they shape our expectations of the world? Yeah, so you can imagine if, you know, I had gone to the doctors that day and they said, your ankle is broken, you can't compete, right? That would be one mindset. That feeling of this ankle is broken, you will not be able to compete, you will feel pain, you will
无法运作的感觉，对吧？这就是期望。我不知何故能够转变为一种心态或信念，即我很好，在面对这个问题时我仍然可以表现，无论我的脚上发生了什么。这导致了这样的期望：我会没事的，我会走上去并发挥出我最高的能力。你能解释一下神经科学家和认知科学家中越来越普遍的观点吗，即大脑作为一种预测机器运作，这意味着什么，阿莉娅？
be not functioning, right? That's the expectation. I was somehow able to shift into a mindset or a belief that I was okay, that I could still perform in the midst of this issue, whatever it was going on in my foot. And that led to the expectation that I was going to be just fine, that I was going to get up there and perform to my highest ability. Can you explain this idea that's increasingly common among neuroscientists and cognitive scientists that the brain operates as a sort of prediction machine, what does that mean, Alia?
是的，大脑的整个目标是试图弄清楚接下来会发生什么，以便它能够为该时刻做准备而准备和优先处理身体现在正在做的事情。所以，再次强调，我们不只是以被动或反应的方式做出回应，我们正在积极主动地思考，好吧，你能够做到这一点吗？这个奶昔或这顿饭会让你有什么感觉？
Yeah, the whole goal of the brain is to try to figure out what's going to happen next so that it can prepare and prioritize what the body is doing now in preparation for that moment. So, again, we're not just responding in a passive or reactive way, we're proactively thinking about, okay, are you going to be able to do this? How is this milkshake or meal going to make you feel?
你得到了足够的锻炼吗？大脑正在对这些预测进行计算和估计，这正在向身体发送信号，说，哦，如果我没有得到足够的食物，我可能需要减慢我的新陈代谢，也许会增强饥饿信号，以便我寻找食物。如果它是，哦，我想我受伤了。我需要向全身发送炎症信号。
Are you getting enough exercise? The brain is calculating and making estimates on those predictions, and that's sending signals back to the body to say, oh, well, if I'm not getting enough food, I need to maybe slow my metabolism down, maybe boost up the hunger signals so I seek out food. If it's, oh, I think I'm hurt. I need to send inflammation signals throughout my body.
我需要向全身发送疼痛信号。我需要向全身发送疼痛信号。所以我坐着并避免活动。因此，我们的大脑不断试图预测将要发生的事情，以便它能够调节我们的身体并为它认为将要发生的事情做好准备。当然，这将塑造大脑所关注的事物。如果你认为我肯定会参加地区赛，这是我需要做的。你的注意力将是，我如何正确执行我的体操动作，而不是
I need to send pain signals throughout my body. I need to send pain signals throughout the body. So I sit and I avoid activity. So our brain is constantly trying to predict what's going to happen so that it can regulate our bodies and prepare it for what it thinks is going to occur. And of course, that's going to shape what the brain pays attention to. If you think I'm definitely going to compete in the regionals and here's what I need to do. Your attention is going to be, how do I execute my gymnastic routine properly as opposed
我的脚踝正经历多少疼痛？对吧。所以预测处理的单纯机制是非常合乎逻辑的，它看起来非常合理，并且它看起来非常客观。就像，好吧，如果我认为这会发生，我会调节我的身体。但是你从一开始就做出的假设
to how much pain is my ankle experiencing? Right. So the sheer mechanism of prediction processing is very logical, it seems very sound, and it seems very objective. It's like, okay, if I think this is going to happen, I'll regulate my body. But the assumption that you made from the beginning
在某种程度上是主观的，对吧？我客观上有一个骨折的脚踝，但有多种方式来解释这一点，对吧？所以这很重要。然后你开始也看到这种连锁反应。因为我们的大脑不能同时处理所有事情，所以它采用这些简化系统。所以它有启发法，它做出假设。
was in some ways subjective, right? I objectively had a broken ankle, but there was a variety of ways to interpret that, right? And so that's important. And then you start to also see this cascade of effects. So because our brains can't process everything at one time, it goes on these simplifying systems. So it has heuristics, it makes assumptions.
因此，如果它认为，好吧，你将能够表现，那么你的注意力系统就会开始注意到你将能够表现的方式。所以我的注意力转移到了，哦，你知道，我感觉很好。对。哦，我其实可以用这只脚走路。对。你开始注意到那些首先证实你预测的事情。这被称为确认偏误。它往往会产生自我实现的循环，因为这样你会得到反馈给那个信念或预测的数据
So if it thinks, okay, you're going to be able to perform then your attention systems start noticing the ways in which you are going to be able to perform. So my attention shifted to, oh, you know, I feel pretty good. Right. Oh, I can actually walk on this foot. Right. You start noticing the things that confirm the prediction that you had in the first place. It's called confirmation bias. And it tends to create the self-fulfilling loop because then you're getting data
。所以在某种程度上，我认为你所说的是，外面世界可能存在客观现实，但当它通过我们的心智时，我们在某种程度上，我认为你所说的是，外面世界可能存在客观现实，但当它通过我们的心智时，我们对于如何处理该客观现实有不同的选择。所以我们可以感知脚踝骨折，我们可以感知脚踝没有骨折。也许要问的更好的问题不是我们的心态的哪个版本最能反映现实，而是要问我们的心态的哪个版本在长期内对我们帮助最大。
that feeds back to that belief or prediction. So in some ways, I think what you're saying is that there might be an objective reality out in the world, but as it comes through our minds, we have different choices in some ways, I think what you're saying is that there might be an objective reality out in the world, but as it comes through our minds, we have different choices in some ways of how we process that objective reality. So we can perceive the ankle is broken, we can perceive the ankle is not broken. And perhaps the better question to ask is not so much which version of our mindset best reflects reality as much as to ask which version of our mindset is going to help us most to the long run.
完全正确。你意识到，你知道，如果你仔细想想，再往前迈出一步，那真是太惊人了，我居然能做到这一点。我应该继续那样做吗？我应该继续相信我没事吗？这可能会导致一些长期的后果。所以，你知道，并不是说某一种心态是对是错，是真是假，对吧？它确实本质上是主观的。但关键是，你拥有的心态
That's exactly right. And you realize, you know, if you think about it and you actually go one step further, it was like, it was amazing that I could do that. Should I have continued doing that? Should I have continued believing that I was fine? That might have led to some long-term consequences. And so, you know, it's not that one mindset is right or wrong, true or false, right? It really is inherently subjective. But the key is that the mindsets that you have
有影响。它们影响你的期望，它们影响你关注的事物，它们影响我们的生理，它们影响我们实际做的事情，因此它们创造了暗示的现实。现在这个过程可能有用也可能无用，它可能是适应性的，也可能是适应不良的，这取决于你所处的情况和环境。
have an effect. They influence what you expect, they influence what you pay attention to, they influence our physiology, and they influence what we actually do, and therefore they create the reality that's implied. Now that process could be useful or not useful, it could be adaptive or it could be maladaptive, depending on the situation and the circumstance that you're in.
把心态想象成我们围绕现实建立的框架可能会有所帮助。不同的框架突出了图片的不同的方面。如果阿莉娅在比赛前拍了X光片，这可能会促使她对脚踝受伤有不同的看法。骨折的脚踝可能会让她想起她感到疼痛或活动受限的所有方式。相反，她围绕伤势建立的框架促使她专注于她能做的事，而不是她不能做的事。需要强调的是，阿莉娅并不是说她的框架是正确的。忽视骨折的脚踝可能会
It may be helpful to think of mindsets as a frame that we put around reality. Different frames highlight different aspects of the picture. If Alia had taken an extra before the competition, it may have prompted her to think of her ankle injury differently. The broken ankle may have brought to mind all the ways in which she was in pain or had limited motion. Instead, the frame she did put around her injury caused her to focus on what she could do, rather than on what she couldn't. It's important to underline that Alia is not saying that her frame was the right one. Ignoring a broken ankle could
导致长期的损伤。她的重点不是她在比赛中的做法是正确的。这是一个大得多的心理学观点。我们所称的现实通常是客观发生的事情和我们如何思考它的混合体。当我们回来时，改变框架的惊人力量。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这被称为地狱周。它是世界上体能要求最高的选拔项目之一。如果你想成为一名美国海豹突击队队员，这就是你必须经历的。
have led to long-term damage. Her point isn't that what she did in the competition was correct. It's a much larger psychological point. What we call reality is usually a mix of what is objectively happening in the world and how we think about it. When we come back, the surprising power of changing the frame. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. It's called Hell Week. It's one of the most physically demanding selection programs in the world. It's what you have to go through if you are going to become a US Navy SEAL.
这是一场无休止的俯卧撑、引体向上和对你尖叫的人的噩梦。心理学家阿莉娅·克拉姆决定，这是更好地理解心态科学的完美环境。我们想看看世界上表现最高的一群人之一，那就是美国海豹突击队。所以这些人去海军是为了成为精英中的精英，他们接受了严酷的训练，对吧，为了成为海豹突击队员。因此，水下爆破海豹突击队训练或海豹突击队基础训练的第一阶段，候选人要经历七周激烈的身心训练。许多人都熟悉这项训练中最残酷的部分，被称为地狱周。
It's an endless dream of push-ups, pull-ups, people screaming at you. Psychologist Aliyah Krum decided that this was the perfect setting to better understand the science of mindsets. We wanted to look at perhaps one of the most highly performing groups of people in the world, and that is US Navy Seals. So these are people who go into the Navy to become the best of the best, and they're put through a grueling training, right, in order to become a seal. So the first phase of the underwater demolition seals training or buds, candidates undergo seven weeks of intense physical and mental training. And a lot of people are familiar with the most grueling part of this training, which is known as Hell Week.
这是候选人几乎不间断地完成任务和演练的时候，你知道，在训练中连续五天半不睡觉。所以我们感兴趣的是观察这些候选人的心态可能会如何影响他们是否能通过爆破训练。我们一直在早期研究压力心态。我们开发了一种测量方法来描述人们对压力的心态。本质上，你是否认为压力是削弱能力的，它会损害你的表现
And this is when candidates complete tasks and drills, almost non-stop, you know, not sleeping for five and a half days of training. So what we were interested in is looking at how these candidates' mindsets might influence whether or not they make it through that demolition training. And we had been studying stress mindset early on. We had developed a measure to characterize people's mindset about stress. Essentially, do you believe that stress is debilitating, that it's going to harm your performance
和生产力以及幸福感？或者你认为压力可以增强，可以提高你的表现并促进你的健康和幸福感？我们表明这种心态存在于一个连续体上。有趣的是，这些海豹突击队员，所以我们测量了他们，这些都是候选人。他们还没有经历过训练。
and productivity and well-being? Or do you believe that stress can be enhancing, can improve your performance and boost your health and well-being? And we show that this mindset rests on a continuum. And what was interesting with these seals, so we measured them, these were all candidates. They hadn't gone through training yet.
首先，我们发现这些候选人具有压力增强型心态。平均而言，他们高于量表的中间点。这是我们测量过的唯一一个具备这种心态的群体。我们看过的每一个其他样本或群体，大型金融公司或科技公司的员工，或者至少美国的本科生，都倾向于认为压力是削弱能力的，而这些人是不同类型的人，这些人是不同的野兽，对吧？他们……这是有道理的，这些人是选择去参加海军海豹突击队训练的人，对吧？他们一定有某种倾向，我只是觉得如果你要在这么一个小小的障碍面前放弃，你将如何……
First of all, what we found was that these candidates had a stress-enhancing mindset. On average, they were over the midpoint of the scale. And that was the only group that we had ever measured that had that. Every other sample or population that we had looked at, employees in large finance firms or tech firms or undergraduates in America at least all tended to have the mindset that stress was debilitating and these were a different type of people these were a different beasts right they and it makes sense these were people who chose to go into Navy seal training right they must have some sort of inclination I just just think that if you're going to quit on this little obstacle, how are you going to
首先，我们发现这些候选人具有压力促进型思维模式。平均而言，他们超过了量表的中点。这是我们测过的唯一有这种特征的群体。我们检查过的其他所有样本或人群，比如大型金融公司或科技公司的员工，或者至少是美国的本科生，往往都认为压力是有害的，而这些人是不同类型的人，是不同的硬汉，对吧？这说得通，这些人是选择去参加海豹突击队训练的人，对吧？他们一定有某种倾向，我只是觉得，如果你连这么小的障碍都要放弃，那你怎么
do another obstacle in life? But what we found in this study, and this was a study I did with former grad student, Eric Smith, we found that their mindsets at the beginning predicted whether or not they would make it through. So it's notoriously hard, 7 to 20% of candidates who start the training completed, only 7 to 20% completed. And what we found was that this one measure, this measure of their mindsets about stress, predicted whether or not they would succeed. So those who had and even more stress is enhancing mindset were more likely to succeed. They also showed
生活中的另一个障碍？但我们在本研究中发现，这是我与前研究生埃里克·史密斯共同完成的一项研究，我们发现他们开始时的心态预示着他们能否成功闯过难关。众所周知，这非常艰难，只有7%到20%开始训练的候选人完成了训练，只有7%到20%的人完成了。我们发现，这一指标，即他们对压力的心态的指标，预示着他们是否会成功。因此，那些拥有甚至更倾向于压力具有提升作用的心态的人更有可能成功。他们还表现出
better performance, objective performance measures on things like the obstacle course test and also higher ratings from their peers. I feel like this is connected with some of the work you've done looking at students in high school and finding the same connection that the people who think that stress is debilitating sometimes do worse than people who have a more positive attitude about stress. Yeah, what we see typically in students and adolescents is that the experience of stress leads to a loss of self-control. So it makes people feel like they're not in control
更好的表现，在障碍赛测试等事情上有客观的表现衡量标准，并且得到了同龄人的更高评价。我觉得这与你所做的一些关于高中生的研究有关，研究发现了同样的认为压力会削弱人的人有时比对压力有更积极态度的人表现得更差的联系。是的，我们在学生和青少年身上通常看到的是，压力的体验会导致自我控制能力的丧失。所以它让人觉得他们无法控制
and that kind of spirals down and has all sort of negative effects on people's lives. And what we've found is that stress mindset severs this link. So, adolescents who believe that stress can be enhancing actually don't have that negative impact on self-control. And if anything, it might go the opposite direction. So you experience stress and you think, okay, this is a cold, dark night. This is part of what it's like to grow up. I can engage more. I can become empowered. I can work through this. I can be resilient. So that's what we've seen there. I understand that you've even tested the effect of explicitly teaching people that stress
这种感觉会呈螺旋式下降，并对人们的生活产生各种负面影响。我们发现的是，压力心态切断了这种联系。因此，相信压力可以起到提升作用的青少年实际上并没有对自我控制产生这种负面影响。如果有的话，它可能会朝着相反的方向发展。所以你经历了压力，你认为，好吧，这是一个寒冷黑暗的夜晚。这是长大成人的一部分。我可以更多地参与进来。我可以变得更有力量。我可以度过难关。我可以更有韧性。这就是我们在那里看到的。据我所知，你甚至测试了明确教导人们压力
can enhance performance. What was the outcome of this instruction for people who were negotiating for a salary increase? Yeah, not study. It was actually appraisals of arousal. So they were experiencing arousal or kind of nervous energy before the salary negotiation. And what we did was give them a simple message that said, hey, you know, this experience of nervousness of nervous arousal before a negotiation is actually a good sign that can help you perform well.
可以提升表现的效果。对于那些谈判加薪的人来说，这种指导的结果是什么？是的，不是研究。这实际上是对唤醒的评估。因此，他们在薪酬谈判之前正在经历唤醒或某种紧张的能量。我们所做的是给他们一个简单的信息，即，嘿，你知道，谈判前紧张唤醒的这种经历实际上是一个好迹象，可以帮助你表现良好。
And that simple message led to improved outcomes on the negotiation. This is taken also from work by Jeremy Jamison and Wendy Mendez and others who have looked at this appraisal of arousal manipulation. And you've looked at other kinds of workplaces as well, right? Where you look at what's the effect of teaching people that stress can be enhancing the effects of this mindset on their performance. Yeah, we've created very seemingly simple videos, films that showcase anecdotes and research and examples,
这个简单的信息带来了更好的谈判结果。这也取材于杰里米·詹姆森、温迪·门德斯和其他人的工作，他们研究了这种对唤醒操纵的评估。你也关注了其他类型的工作场所，对吧？你研究了教导人们压力可以增强心态对他们表现的影响的效果。是的，我们创作了看似非常简单的视频、电影，展示了轶事、研究和例子，
all true, presenting this case, you know, that stress can have enhancing effects on our lives and our well-being. And what we've shown is just watching these short videos, there, three minutes in some cases. Not only leads to a change in mindset about stress, but confers benefits in terms of greater work performance, fewer negative health symptoms, and other positive outcomes. Contrast this research with the way we usually talk about stress. For decades now, we have been talking about stress as a poison to be avoided.
全都是真的，提出了这样一个观点，即压力会对我们的生活和幸福产生提升作用。我们所展示的是，仅仅观看这些短片，在某些情况下长达三分钟。不仅能改变对压力的心态，还能带来更大的工作绩效、更少的负面健康症状和其他积极结果方面的益处。将这项研究与我们通常谈论压力的方式进行对比。几十年来，我们一直将压力视为一种应避免的毒药。
In workplaces, busy people walk around saying, I'm so stressed, I need a vacation. Few of us stop to ask, what effect these worries about stress might have on our well-being? All of these warnings and messages are well-intentioned. It makes sense, right? It's like, oh, we find out that stress could have a negative impact. We should tell everybody about that, right? It's like, oh, we find out that stress could have a negative impact. We should tell everybody about that, right?
在工作场所，忙碌的人四处走动说，我压力太大了，我需要度假。很少有人停下来问，这些对压力的担忧可能会对我们的幸福产生什么影响？所有这些警告和信息都是出于好意。这说得通，对吧？就像，哦，我们发现压力可能会产生负面影响。我们应该把这件事告诉所有人，对吧？就像，哦，我们发现压力可能会产生负面影响。我们应该把这件事告诉所有人，对吧？
Like, let's warn them. But when you start to become aware of the role of mindsets, you realize that what we're unintentionally doing and sending those messages out is creating mindsets that might be unhelpful and perhaps even counterproductive in our goals. So when you learn that stress is going to kill you, what does that do when you're stressed? It makes you more stressed, right? Now not only do you have to deal with the stress of this pandemic and your daycare closing
就像，让我们警告他们。但当你开始意识到心态的作用时，你就会意识到我们无意中在做的事情和发出的那些信息正在创造可能无助的心态，甚至可能对我们的目标产生反作用。所以当你得知压力会害死你时，你在压力下会做什么？这让你压力更大，对吧？现在你不仅要应付这场大流行的压力和你日托中心的关闭
for the fourth time, but now you have to stress about the stress. And so when you recognize that that mindset matters, you can kind of reverse engineer and think back to, well, what would be a useful mindset here? What mindset about stress would be helpful? Now if we could easily reduce stressors in our life, it might be the warning, right? But that's just not the case. We do not often have the ability and or luxury to reduce this amount of stress we're experiencing. And as we've discussed, if you do remove all stress, you also remove all cares. You remove those values, you remove the things that matter to you. Being a parent is stressful.
第四次了，但现在你必须为压力感到压力。因此，当你认识到这种心态很重要时，你可以进行逆向工程，回想一下，在这里什么才是有用的心态？关于压力的什么心态会有所帮助？现在，如果我们能轻易地减少生活中的压力源，这可能是个警告，对吧？但事实并非如此。我们通常没有能力和/或奢侈来减少我们所经历的压力。正如我们所讨论的，如果你真的消除了所有的压力，你也消除了所有的牵挂。你消除了那些价值观，你消除了对你重要的事情。做父母是有压力的。
Succeeding in a career is stressful. Being an athlete of any kind is stressful, right? Life is stressful and that's okay, right? So when we start to realize that, then you say, what mindset would be useful here? And that's how we've kind of landed on this mindset that stress can be enhancing, along with Brett Logan's sage advice. I want to take a few beats here and underline some important caveats. It's one thing to say, mindsets are powerful. It's smart to pay attention to our mindsets and to ask if they are helping us or hurting us. But it's not smart to believe our mindsets can be the solution to every problem.
在职业生涯中取得成功是有压力的。做任何种类的运动员都是有压力的，对吧？生活充满压力，这没关系，对吧？所以当我们开始意识到这一点时，你就会说，这里什么心态会有所帮助？这就是我们如何最终得出这种心态的原因，即压力可以增强，连同布雷特·洛根的明智建议。我想在这里花一点时间，强调一些重要的警告。说心态很强大是一回事。关注我们的心态，并询问它们是在帮助我们还是在伤害我们是明智的。但认为我们的心态可以成为每个问题的解决方案是不明智的。
Surely, I asked Alia, if we need to guard against well-intentioned people who tell us that stress is always bad, we also need to be cautious if people tell us that stress is always good. Yeah, when we do this research, often the first goal is to just point out that your mindset is playing a role. But what often happens is people take that and then they run with it, right? And then they assume it's sort of all or nothing.
当然，我问莉亚，如果我们必须防范那些总是告诉我们压力不好的好心人，如果人们告诉我们压力总是好的，我们也必须谨慎。是的，当我们做这项研究时，通常的首要目标只是指出你的心态正在发挥作用。但经常发生的情况是，人们接受这一点然后继续奔跑，对吧？然后他们假设这有点全或无。
Well, if stress is enhancing, we should just lay it on our employees, right? And that is the last thing that I would want people to take away from this. What I want people to realize is that the total effect of anything is a combined product of what you're actually doing and what you think about what you do. So mindset's influence our lives, but they are just a piece of the puzzle. And it's just a piece of the puzzle that I think we haven't played enough attention to. And then the other thing I would say is that don't jump to conclusions about what the right mindset is.
好吧，如果压力能提升，我们就应该把它强加给我们的员工，对吧？这就是我最不希望人们从中吸取的东西。我想让人们意识到的是，任何事物的总体效果都是你实际在做的事情和对你所做事情的想法的综合产物。所以心态会影响我们的生活，但它们只是拼图的一部分。这只是拼图的一部分，我认为我们没有给予足够的关注。然后我要说的另一件事是，不要对正确的心态是什么下结论。
What is right or what is adaptive depends on the circumstance. So there might be a breaking point in which having a stress is enhancing mindset is helpful, but that doesn't mean you shouldn't reduce unnecessary stressors. It also, I think this is really important, the work on mindsets, it's really empowering to the individual. And that's great. But we also want to make sure that people don't feel like it's all up to them to change their realities because you just change your mindset and everything will be fine. Your mindset will help. But you know, the reality matters too. And also, you have mindsets because of the reality that we live in.
什么是对的或什么是适应性的取决于环境。所以可能有一个临界点，在这个临界点上拥有压力就是提升心态是有帮助的，但这并不意味着你不应该减少不必要的压力源。此外，我认为这真的很重要，关于心态的工作，它对个人真的很有赋权。这很棒。但我们也希望确保人们不会觉得一切都取决于他们来改变他们的现实，因为你只要改变你的心态，一切都会好起来的。你的心态会有所帮助。但你知道，现实也很重要。而且，你之所以有心态，是因为我们生活的现实。
Why do we have the mindset that stresses debilitating? Because we live in a culture where these messages are everywhere, right? So, being empowered by this, but also, you know, recognize that it's not all you that there are forces shaping your mindsets. So we need to be aware of those two. And then we need to change systems and structures in our society to hopefully generate better cultural mindsets. I've often found that it's one thing to have insights about how our minds work. And another thing to put those insights into practice in our own lives.
为什么我们会有压力会削弱人的心态？因为我们生活在一个这些信息无处不在的文化中，对吧？所以，在获得赋权的同时，也要认识到这不完全是你，还有塑造你心态的力量。所以我们也需要意识到这一点。然后我们需要改变我们社会中的系统和结构，以期产生更好的文化心态。我经常发现，对我们的思维如何运作有见解是一回事。将这些见解付诸我们自己的生活实践则是另一回事。
And that's true not just for ordinary mortals like me, but even researchers like you who have made the discoveries about these insights. Some time ago, Alia, you were giving an important speech and you were a little nervous. I want to play you a little clip of you yourself talking at the TED conference.
对于像我这样的普通凡人来说不仅如此，甚至对你们这些对这些见解做出发现的研究人员来说也是如此。不久前，莉亚，你正在发表一次重要的演讲，你有点紧张。我想给你播放一段你自己TED大会上讲话的小片段。
The placebo effect is not about the faux pill, or the sugar pill, or the fake procedure. What the placebo effect really is, is a powerful, robust, and consistent demonstration of the ability of our mindsets. In this case, the expectation to heal, to recruit healing properties in the body. So, Alia, I can hear your voice shaking in that clip, and the reason I played it is not to show that you were nervous during the talk, but because during the talk, you realized that you were stressed, you realized that you were nervous, and you employed some of the
安慰剂效应不是关于假药，或糖丸，或虚假的程序。安慰剂效应真正代表的是，对我们心态能力的强大、稳健和一致的证明。在这种情况下，治愈的期望，在体内招募治愈特性。所以，莉亚，我能听到你在那段视频中声音在颤抖，我播放它的原因不是为了显示你在演讲中很紧张，而是因为在演讲期间，你意识到你压力很大，你意识到你很紧张，并且你运用了一些
techniques and insight that you had learned about mindsets to change what you did, the rest of the talk. Tell me what you did. Yeah, I mean, this was a big talk. This was an opportunity to get out, some of the research I had done and share it with the whole world on the internet. And as I started speaking, my nerves were conveyed in, as you show there, the quivering of my voice. And I could notice myself doing that. And you know, it would have been real easy to just say, oh my god, this is a disaster. I need to run off the stage. But what I did mentally was just remind myself that I was here for a reason that I had an important message to say, and that, of course, I was nervous. This mattered. It mattered to me, and I felt like it could matter to others. And so that feeling of, this is worth it, this matters, kept me going to the end.
你学到的关于心态的技术和见解，改变了你所做的事情，演讲的其余部分。告诉我你做了什么。是的，我的意思是，这是一场重要的演讲。这是一个走出去的机会，我做了一些研究，并在互联网上与全世界分享。当我开始说话时，正如你在那里展示的那样，我的紧张通过我的声音颤抖传达出来。我能注意到自己在这样做。你知道，如果直接说“哦，天哪，这是一场灾难。我需要跑下舞台”会非常容易。但我精神上所做的只是提醒自己，我来这里是有原因的，我有一个重要的信息要说，而且，当然，我很紧张。这很重要。这对我很重要，我觉得它对别人也很重要。所以那种“这是值得的，这很重要”的感觉让我坚持到了最后。
In some ways I think what I hear you saying is that when you reinterpret stress not as evidence of your inadequacy, but as evidence of how much you care about something, it can transform the way you think about it. That's exactly right. It was so important. And you know, if I'm being honest, I got off the stage. I knew I did, got the message out, you know, but I was totally distraught because I felt like I was not at my peak, you know, I was, I did it. I said what I wanted to say, but it was obviously nervous. Everybody's
在某些情况下，我认为我听到你所说的是，当你将压力重新诠释为不是你不够优秀的证据，而是你对某事有多关心的证据时，它可以改变你对它的看法。完全正确。这太重要了。你知道，如果我诚实的话，我走下了舞台。我知道我做到了，把信息传达出去了，但我完全心烦意乱，因为我觉得我没有达到巅峰，你知道，我做到了。我说了我想说的话，但显然很紧张。每个人都会
going to know, nobody's going to watch this, and I was so mad at myself for that. And that anger also came from a place of like, I cared, I wanted this to be great. And fortunately I gave myself some slack. And who knows, who knows what would have happened with that TEDx talk where I had been perfect throughout all. But I do think there's something powerful in people seeing the human behind the work. That was me, right? This is me now. This is the work we've done. This is what we've learned
都会知道，没有人会看这个，我为此对自己非常生气。这种愤怒也来自于一种关心、希望这一切变得伟大的地方。幸运的是，我对自己放松了一些。谁知道呢，如果我的TEDx演讲一直都很完美，会发生什么事呢。但我确实认为，人们看到作品背后的真人具有强大的力量。那是我，对吧？现在是我。这是我们所做的工作。这是我们所学到的
so far. It's been useful, but it's just the beginning. I'm learning. We're all learning. And that's what I'm really looking forward to doing in the next 20, 30, 40 years of my career is just keep learning on an academic level, but also learning and growing on a personal level. on a personal level. Mindsets can change the way we approach a difficult conversation at work or a physically demanding assignment. Changing your mindset can change the way we think about stress and setbacks. But all of the ideas we have discussed today, explore the effects of mindsets on our attitudes, motivation,
到目前为止。这很有用，但这只是个开始。我在学习。我们都在学习。这就是我真正期待在我职业生涯的下一个20、30、40年中要做的事情，不仅仅是在学术层面上继续学习，而且在个人层面上也在学习和成长。在个人层面上。心态可以改变我们对待工作中困难对话或体能要求高的任务的方式。改变你的心态可以改变我们对压力和挫折的看法。但我们今天讨论的所有想法，都探讨了心态对我们的态度、动机的影响，
and perception. They look at how mindsets affect the mind. In part two of our story, we will look at something even stranger. Is it possible that our mindsets don't just change our minds, but that they can change our physical bodies? What we found was that simply informing them that their work was good exercise led to changes in their health. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
和感知。他们研究心态如何影响思维。在我们故事的第二部分，我们将看到更奇怪的事情。我们的心态不仅能改变我们的想法，还能改变我们的身体，这可能吗？我们发现的是，仅仅通知他们他们的工作是很好的锻炼就会导致他们健康的变化。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor. Our unsung hero this week is Devon Trainor, a manager with our ad sales and distribution partner, Stitcher. Not long ago, we started receiving messages from listeners reporting they were having problems accessing our show on Google podcasts. Devon sprang into action, working with staff at Google until the problem was fixed.
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是德文·特雷纳，我们广告销售和分发合作伙伴Stitcher的经理。不久前，我们开始收到听众的报告，称他们在谷歌播客上访问我们的节目时遇到问题。德文立即采取行动，与谷歌的工作人员合作，直到问题得到解决。
There was lots of troubleshooting over several days, but we knew Devon wouldn't stop working on it until there was a solution. Thank you Devon. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam.
经过几天的故障排除，但我们知道德文不会停止工作，直到有了解决方案。谢谢你，德文。如果您喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次，如果您想帮助支持您喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子发表评论。